الان خريطه التطورات الميدانيه الاخرى في
الجبهتين الشرقيه والجنوبيه لاوكرانيا
خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيا
مثلا في فقه مقاطعه خار كيف ما زال تركيز
القوات الروسيه مستمرا على مدينه كوبياسك
تستهدف الهجمات الروسيه بالصواريخ
والغارات الجويه نقاط تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه والعتاد هناك وكذلك مستودعات
الذخيره ومراكز القياده بينما يتواصل
اجلاء المدنيين اما هجمات القوات
الاوكرانيه فمستمره في باخموت بمقاطعه
وتتركز الهجمات الاوكرانيه على الناحيتين
الجنوبيه والشماليه
للمدينه في زفروجيا مثلا
يدور قتال عنيف في بلده اوروبوتينا وهي
بلده استراتيجيه تسعى اوكرانيا لاستعادتها
ومن خلالها يمكن فتح الطريق نحو
وصولا الى بحر ازوف وهو المحور الذي ما
زالت تحت السيطره الروسيه